Casually watching a video on YouTube, on a computer,
more powerful than anything. Humanity could build a few decades ago,
this progress and all the wonderful machines you take for granted are built on a
few rare and precious materials with names like Terbium neodymium or
tantalum.
Getting these raw materials from the ground into your devices is ugly.
The mining industry is responsible for air and water pollution and the
destruction of entire landscapes,
dangerous chemicals like Sinai sulfuric acid or chlorine are used to extract
the resources,
harming biodiversity workers and locals and rare resources are
also political tools when countries restrict access to them to get their way.
But what if we could replace the mining industry on earth with a clean process
that can't harm anyone? Well, we can,
all we need to do is look up.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] are millions of trillions of tons of rocks,
metals and ice leftovers from the cloud that became the planets 4.5 billion
years ago.
They can be as small as a meter or protoplanets the size of entire countries.
Most of them are concentrated in the asteroid belt and the Kuiper belt while
hundreds of thousands more do their own thing between the planets as space
travel is becoming more feasible. Scientists and economists have begun.
Looking at the resources found in these asteroids,
even relatively small metallic asteroids that may contain trillions worth of
industrial and precious metals like platinum and bigger asteroids,
like 16 psyche could contain enough iron nickel to cover the world's metal needs
for millions of years. At current market prices,
the rat rule materials alone would be worth quadrillions of dollars. Well,
not really, but technically for example,
there are more than 20 million tons of gold in the oceans water worth,
roughly 750 trillion us dollars,
but filtering out the gold would be so expensive that you'd lose money sending
it right now. Asteroid mining has exactly this problem.
It's too expensive to replace mining on earth.
Billions of dollars worth of valuable resources in space are worthless.
If it costs trillions to get them what makes it so hard?
The principles behind mining an asteroid, a simple,
the basic idea is to choose the asteroid,
move it to a place where it's easy to process and then take it apart to turn
into useful products. Unfortunately,
all of this collides with fundamental problems humans have yet to solve,
going to space is expensive.
It costs thousands of dollars in rocket fuel for each kilogram,
just to reach a low earth orbit going further out into deep space costs
thousands more.
We need cheapest space travel to make asteroid mining profitable.
One solution is to switch from classical rocket to electric spaceships.
We already use rocket engines for many of the space probes on science missions.
In principle,
we only need to build bigger ones while electrical engines are not powerful
enough to fly to space. They require only a tiny amount of fuel to go very far.
Once they're in space,
this means we don't need to spend a lot of money on fuel only to transport fuel
into space. This doesn't solve the whole cost problem,
but it makes it easiest to start our first mission.
Now that we have an electric asteroid mining spaceship,
we need to find the right asteroid and get it there.
We've already successfully visited asteroids with space probes and even
collected samples still to make it easier and cheaper.
Our first targets will probably beat near earth asteroids asteroids
well near earth. After a few months of travel,
our spaceship finally arrives at our,
the restaurant weirdly formed littered with small numbers at craters.
It hasn't changed much for billions of years.
The first thing that needs to be done is to secure the asteroid and stop it from
spinning.
There are multiple ways to do this like vaporizing material with a laser or
stopping the rotation with thrusters. Once we have a stable asteroid,
we need to wait. Orbital mechanics are complicated,
but if you push something in the right direction at exactly the right moment,
you can move very big things with very little.
So we wait for exactly the right moment,
fires it thrusters and nudges the astroid into a trajectory that takes it near
our moon.
The moon is useful because we can borrow it's gravitational pull to put the
asteroid in a stable or wet earth, which saves even more fuel. Again,
the trip takes months.
All the time since our ship was launched has not been wasted.
The first space mining and processing equipment has been installed in always,
and is now carefully moving towards the asteroid.
The processor works very differently than on earth. Giant mirrors, focus,
sunlight and heat up asteroid rock to boil out the gases grinders break up the
dry rocks into gravel and dust and centrifuges separate dense from light
elements.
Even if we only extract 0.01% of the asteroids mass in precious metals,
this is still several times more than you'd get from the same amount of,
or on the ground. But what now?
How do we get our precious metals safely back to ground?
There are a few ways like loading it into reusable rockets that return to earth
from space. Or if our processor contains 3d printers,
we can print a faster and cheaper delivery system.
Heat shielded capsules filled with gas bubbles.
These can just be dropped into the oceans where ships tow them away.
This could be the starting point of humanity's first real steps towards
colonizing this solar system.
As our infrastructure and experience grows down,
missions get more and more sophisticated parts and fuel produced on asteroids.
Don't have to be launched from earth at all.
The first mining operation makes the second one easier and so on.
While space industry grows and precious materials become cheaper.
Eventually we could stop mining on earth.
Even the idea of toxic mining down here might become something weird.
And acronystic like having an open fire in your living room.
Landscapes ravaged by pollution will heal while the technological wonders were
used to get cheaper and less toxic to make none of this is science
fiction.
We don't need fancy materials or new physics to make asteroid mining happen.
We could start building this future today.
All we need is an initial quote.
Maybe.
You could also use a little nudge not to pursue anything as ambitious as
asteroid mining, just to try something new and fun.
Let us give you some tailwind there. We partnered with Skillshare,
an online learning community with thousands of classes in all kinds of creative
skills, like graphic design, music, photography, illustration, and animation.
They have something for every skill level.
So no matter from where you're starting,
there'll be tons of things for you to explore.
If you'd like to take a glimpse behind the scenes of our animations.
For example,
we've made a couple of Skillshare classes that teach you how we animated scenes
from our videos, with the video lessons, classes and hands-on projects,
or if you'd rather come up with your own characters to breathe life into,
we recommend character illustration from concept to final artwork by Matt coffin
Berg, but it doesn't really matter what you pick. As long as you get started,
improve your skills and have some fun unlimited access to all classes is only
$10 a month with an annual premium membership.
But we have a treat for the first 1000 coats cause aren't viewers to click the
link in the description. You'll get a two month trial for free.
If you want to leave your comfort zone by exploring new skills and support cost
zones, give it a try.
[Inaudible].